Amber Rose embraces the sexy and
addresses her controversy with julianne
hough on Dancing with the Stars
have you two had a chance to chat
Julianne during the week no we haven't
had a chance
since called last week amber dance to
booty by JLo and Julianne said this
afterwards on her podcast amber revealed
she felt body shamed by that comment
from Julianne who then responded in a
statement to ET saying she was solely
judging Amber's dancing and nothing else
Monday night viewers saw what happened
behind the scenes I've literally phone
down my ass shaking on purpose because I
knew that they were gonna say my body's
too sexy
in jail
and amber decided to go even harder with
her sexiness for Monday night's dance
this week I'm just gonna embrace my
sexuality and not apologize for it
demand it is all about embracing
sexuality turn last week I think I made
a mistake I should have pushed amber all
the way she danced the tango with
partner Max and amber and Julianne spoke
to each other in person for the first
time when you said that is how very
embarrassed and I felt like you weren't
talking about my desk but if I
misunderstood then I apologized as a
judge on the show I'm here to solely
judge you and everyone else in this
competition for only the dancing so I
want you to know that well camber and
Max wound up with three eights this to
me is your essence this is who you are
you were stripped down this is
authentically you
you